voilà et j'accueille maintenant dave
va nous arrêter d'aller leur match et
vous vous levez tête comme ça incroyable
je suis peut-être un peu moins chiant
mais montrer ça mais ça va très bien
vous connaissez tous le monde ici voyez
intimement consommé au plaisir la pub
est facile et ni les battre et les nuits
que pitau virgile close and l'héroïne
des rois mages venus au fil des inconnus
santoro que gagner un match de tennis en
australie qui dit joyce chez les
messieurs ça va ça va bien dave on voit
une fois par an c'est très bien mais
c'est plus que ma tante
c'est à chaque fois que quand même
chercher après du tout non il n'y avait
pas de l'allusion
c'est à dire à chaque fois que vous
sortez une compilation de vos anciens
succès vous savez comment on fait avec
les petites mains comme ça
pas fait